[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und marietta slomka
guten abend wir blicken zuerst nach
österreich das gegen einen amtierenden
bundeskanzler wegen des verdachts der
falschaussage ermittelt wird ist an sich
schon beachtlich und das ist eine ganze
menge was die wiener wirtschaft zur
korruptionsstaatsanwaltschaft
zusammengetragen hat jenseits einer
strafrechtlichen bewertung liefern die
privaten chats die sebastian kurz laut
aktenlage mit seinen getreuen
austauschte bemerkenswerte einblicke als
es um die vergabe eines der lukrativsten
posten in österreich geht tippte der
kanzler ein munteres kriegst eh alles
was du willst in die tasten mit herzchen
und smileys garniert der so bedachte
freute sich das sei grenzgenial und
werde echt cool
ebenfalls mit herzchen smileys garniert
wie gesagt da ging es um einen der top
jobs in österreich
das wirft unangenehme fragen auf heute
auch in einer sondersitzung des
parlaments britta hilpert berichtet aus
wie man kann sebastian kurz auf dem
kragen ansehen wasser von einem termin
hält schlitz trägt da wenn es groß und
wichtig ist dieser nationalrat so zeigt
er ist es wohl nicht es geht absolut und
ausschließlich nur darum andere zu
diffamieren zu beschädigen und irgendwie
zu vernichten
die opposition wenn ihn vernichten so
erklärt er sich die anzeige die
ermittlungen gegen ihn
die opposition spricht von täter opfer
umkehr von der politischen kultur
gesprochen wird wie wenn so viel wenn
die brandstifter sich in stellung
gemacht es ist so arg es gibt so viele
brände
es sind nicht die mitglieder der
opposition
als beschuldigte geführt werden sondern
es sind vertreter ihrer partei
wir wollen dass diese republik eine hieß
für die wir uns nicht schämen müssen und
ich will daher dass die konsequenzen
wenn es zur anklage kommt auch gezogen
werden
treten dann einfach zu kurz was heute
hier entrüstet begann vor zwei jahren
mit dem ibiza video zeigt wie der
spätere rechtspopulistische vize kanzler
strache macht missbrauchen wollte kurz
schwarz blaue regierungskoalition
zerbrach an den nächsten partner die
grünen stellte der kanzler und sprüche
und darüber hinaus ist natürlich auch
die frage wer hat ja das moralische
potenzial eine regierung zu führen und
mit wem kann man stabil auch regieren
doch ibiza holt auch kurz ein
ermittlungen zu dem video zu
machtmissbrauch und postenschacher
erfassen seine vertrauten sein
kabinettschef sein finanzminister und
den neuen chef der staatsholding öiag
der wichtigste wirtschaftsboss tten der
republik ging an thomas schmid
mutmaßlich weil er zur türkischen
familie gehört so lesen es ermittler in
chat protokollen und kurz war mutmaßlich
beteiligt kriegst du alles was du willst
schreibt der kanzler an schmidt der
antwortet ich liebe meinen kanzler im
untersuchungsausschuss bestreitet kurz
einfluss für schmidt genommen zu haben
verdachts auf falschaussage die anklage
sei wahrscheinlich meint sogar kurz
selbst
der schaden ist jetzt aber er schon da
diese ursprungs botschaft des neuen
stils politik anders machen zu wollen
dass dieser nimbus von damals natürlich
weg ist der jüngste brach einst mit
österreichs tradition großer koalitionen
neu auch die partnerschaft mit den
grünen wenn die ihn womöglich nicht mehr
stützen bei anklage oder urteil ist das
mehr als eine etappe niederlage
sebastian kurz kann auch kein
gesteigertes interesse daran haben quasi
als eine art schwarze witwe da in die
geschichte der zweiten republik
einzugehen also einer der
vier jahren drei koalitionspartner
verbraucht es kann seine schwerste krise
in den jungen politiker leben werden
sebastian kurz hat immer überrascht er
tut es weiter in jeder hinsicht
ich habe vertiefen und was noch ein
bisschen britta hilpert in wien kann es
eng werden für kurze aber jetzt noch
nicht es gibt ja noch zwei weitere
eskalationsstufen sozusagen zum einen
eine anklage die scheint zumindest nicht
völlig ausgeschlossen und zum zweiten
ein mögliches urteil aber bis dahin
werden ja noch einige monate ins land
ziehen oder ja aber das werden spannende
monate würde ich sagen denn es laufen ja
mehrere ermittlungen gegen mehrere
spitzenpolitiker der kurz partei cvp
was kommt da noch raus ist die frage zum
zweiten muss kurz natürlich jetzt seinen
koalitionspartner die grünen enger an
sich binden was bietet er ihnen dafür an
und wird das reichen um eine mögliche
anklage und mögliche urteile zu
überstehen
und zum dritten herrscht hier jetzt
wirklich eine ausgabe aufgeheizte
gespaltener atmosphäre im land
und da ist die frage wie diese
politische spaltung wieder überwunden
oder zumindest gemildert werden kann
es werden also spannende tage würde ich
sagen in staatsanwaltschaft büros hinter
verschlossenen koalitions türen und
natürlich auch im parlament auf jeden
fall bleibt interessant
dankeschön dritter nach wie derweil
gehen die kämpfe in nahost weiter
zwar mehren sich die internationalen
forderungen nach einer waffenruhe
auch bundeskanzlerin merkel sagte heute
den israelischen premierminister
sie hoffe auf ein möglichst zeitnah es
ende doch diese zeit ist offenbar noch
nicht bekommen
jedenfalls nicht für israel das einen
krieg an mehr als einer front führt zum
einen will israels führung der hamas
klarmachen dass sie sich mit ihrem
raketenangriffen militärisch
verkalkuliert hat zugleich wird mit
jedem einschlag in gaza auch der im
benachbarten libanon sitzenden hisbollah
eine warnung gesendet sie ist für israel
der noch gefährlichere feind und so wird
in gaza haben wohl auch ein exempel
statuiert mit dem ausmaß haben die
führer der hamas möglicherweise nicht
gerechnet
sie verliert
täglich mann und material die größten
verluste aber trägt ihr volk berichtet
michael ist gleich der aufgabe des
sisyphos was den städtischen
mitarbeitern von gaza city jeden tag
bevorsteht die zerschossenen
stromleitungen wieder verbinden und noch
wichtiger die zerstörten wasserleitungen
flicken denn wasser wird knapp in gaza
hier hier als harry behält im
kriegsgeschehen die ruhe
obwohl er weiß dass all die geflickten
leitungen am nächsten tag an anderer
stelle zerbombt sind die einwohner
leiden unter der wasserknappheit jeden
tag melden sich fast 200 anrufer die uns
darum bitten ihre wasserversorgung
wieder herzustellen
wir haben es zu unserer top priorität
gemacht vor allem die großen wohnblocks
mit wasser zu versorgen
die flüchtlinge aus dem besonders
attackierten norden müssen um wasser mit
kanistern anstehen sie haben in einer
schule der un zuflucht gefunden
wir hoffen dass wir bald in unsere
häuser zurückkehren können denn hier
haben wir kaum wasser und nichts zu
essen
doch noch sieht es nicht nach einem
waffenstillstand aus bomben fallen
raketen steigen auf die schlugen heute
besonders heftig in erstein auch dort
leidet die zivilbevölkerung
mein junge hat die ganze zeit geweint
ich will nicht sterben ich will nicht
sterben rief er ich habe ihm gesagt dass
wir nicht sterben werden dass wir sicher
sind
[Musik]
die usa haben ihre stille diplomatie
beendet und fordern nun offen das
sofortige ende der gewalt
palästinenser und israelis haben wie
alle menschen das recht in ruhe und
sicherheit zu leben das ist kein
israelisches oder palästinensisches
vorrecht das ist ein menschenrecht dass
durch die gegenwärtige gewalt mit füßen
getreten wird der hamas käme ein
waffenstillstand entgegen längst hat sie
ihr kriegs ziel erreicht und mit ihren
raketen die verwundbarkeit der
israelischen städte bloßgelegt und viele
palästinenser und arabische israelis
haben sich mit ihrem kurs der gewalt
solidarisiert doch wann ist israels
kriegsziel erreicht möglichst viel der
militärischen infrastruktur der hamas zu
zerstören
längst geht es darum die deutungshoheit
zu erringen wer aus diesem konflikt als
sieger hervorgeht das
sicherheitskabinett beschließt daher am
abend weiter zu machen
der beschluss lautet terroristische
ziele weiter anzugreifen die armee macht
das sehr gut wir werden das notwendige
tun um ruhe und sicherheit für alle
israelis wieder herzustellen
wann das sein wird hat mit herrn ja
nicht gesagt couch liegen im nahen osten
wieder raketen und bomben wird jetzt
lande kommt der antisemitismus wieder
laut nicht dass er nicht immer da wäre
aber jeder krieg zwischen israel und
palästinensern die führt den
einschlägigen gruppen einen willkommenen
anlass zur enthemmung auf der straße
zeigte sich in den letzten tagen vor
allem der eingewanderten judenhass aus
arabischen und anderen muslimischen
communitys
aber der einheimische sozusagen original
deutsche antisemitismus ist auch mit
stadtteils verbrennt als israelkritik
auch das sind altbekannte muster daneben
die variante von rechts in form von
solidarität mit israel gegen muslime
gern aus mündern die bei anderer
gelegenheit schamlos antisemitische kurz
auf der zunge tragen
all diese facetten sind nicht neu und
dennoch nieder schritt hat dann herzen
und sarah wagner berichten wenn salomo
ist jüdischer rebellion antisemitismus
kennt er in all seinen hässlichen
schattierungen zigfach ist der in
schulen gegangen um dagegen anzukämpfen
aufzuklären vor allem auch mit
muslimischen jugendlichen ins gespräch
zu kommen
ich habe die erfahrung gemacht dass wenn
man an schulen geht und auch mit
muslimischen jugendlichen spricht sie
sind sehr interessiert an an wissen sie
haben ganz viel halbwissen gerüchte
lügen über juden die sie vielleicht in
ihren elternhäusern gelernt haben oder
auch durch die medien bekommen haben
kolportierte haste durch die aktuellen
ereignisse neu genährt wird und auch in
seinen alltag ragt drohung bekomme er
immer nur noch mal sehr viel mehr so
erreicht der aufflammende konflikt
deutschland auf vielfältige weise zur
besorgnis der bundesregierung
solch eine einstellung ist in
deutschland inakzeptabel
das muss jeder wissen und es muss auch
jedem mit den mitteln des rechtsstaats
klargemacht werden dass es so weit
kommen konnte habe die politik selbst
mitverursacht sagt
politikwissenschaftler ab der zermatt
aus sorge vor einem erstarken der
rechten vermutet er habe man
eingewanderten antisemitismus nicht
ausreichend thematisiert
es kommen viele migranten aus syrien aus
dem irak aus dem libanon aus ägypten und
diese migranten haben den antisemitismus
in ihren ländern
quasi mit der muttermilch vermittelt
bekommen
antisemitismus gehört zur
bildungspolitik in der arabischen welt
ich habe das in ägypten in der schule
vermittelt bekommen judenhass
verschwörungstheorien dass der großteil
der muslime in deutschland
antisemitismus ablehne sei dabei ebenso
zu betonen wie die anderen formen des
antisemitismus hierzulande vor allem von
rechts
beides aber dürfe nicht dazu führen
islamistischen antisemitismus zu
relativieren fordern auch strafverfolger
wir dürfen jetzt nicht den fehler machen
nur darauf warten dass die rechten
irgendwelche texte ab sondern die mit
einfachen botschaften versehen sind
sondern wir müssen in der breite der
gesellschaft auch darüber diskutieren
dass wir in der zuwanderungs
gesellschaft ebenfalls einen weit
verbreiteten antisemitismus haben
ähnliches diagnostizierte felix klein
schon vor drei jahren als erster
antisemitismus beauftragter der
bundesregierung wurde seither sei viel
umgesetzt worden eine bund länder
kommission eingesetzt ein
wissenschaftlicher beratungs kreis eine
erfassung aller antisemitischen vorfälle
und langfristige forschungsförderungen
auch haben wir gesetzliche maßnahmen
eingeführt das gesetz gegen hass und
hetze im internet die verhetzende
beleidigung ist dieser tage vom
bundeskabinett verabschiedet worden dass
das kommen soll
es ist glaube ich viel zu tun aber es
ist immer noch nicht genug entschiedenes
handeln sei daher
mehr denn je gefragt so abdel-samad
damit es nicht ausgehe wie in frankreich
wo auch alles mit protesten begann dann
hat der staat die kontrolle über den
islamismus und über die migrations
situation verloren und jetzt leider in
frankreich verlassen die juden
frankreich und gehen richtung israel
und wenn das auch in deutschland
passiert dann hat deutschland einen
historischen fehler gemacht ben salomo
der jüdische rapper aus berlin ist
ähnlich alarmiert der kampf gegen
vorurteile für verständigung er wird nun
nicht einfacher ihn nicht zu führen aber
sei keine option
zu dem thema gibt es nach dem
heute-journal update ein gespräch mit
dem psychologen und extras extremismus
expertenrat mansur und jetzt macht
erstmal weiter mit anderen errichten die
pläne für einen neuen europäischen
kampfjet kommen nach monatelangen
verhandlungen voran
es ist das größte europäische
rüstungsprojekt auf das sich die
verteidigungsministerien von deutschland
frankreich und spanien verständigt haben
nun kann sich der bundestag mit der
finanzierung des neuen luftkampf systems
befassen
etwa 1,2 milliarden euro müssen im
verteidigungshaushalt für die
entwicklung des eurofighter nachfolgers
kalkuliert werden
die deutsche hilfsorganisation hat bei
mehreren einsätzen im mittelmeer über
400 menschen aus seenot gerettet
unter den geflüchteten seien viele
kinder sowie ein acht monate altes baby
und eine schwangere frau
wie die zivilen seenotretter berichten
brechen die migranten meist von libyen
und tunesien
in richtung italien auf laut uno starben
in diesem jahr bislang mehr als 600
menschen bei dem versuch das mittelmeer
nach europa zu überqueren
großbritannien lockert die korona
beschränkungen von heute an weiter trotz
der sorge vor einer ausbreitung der sehr
ansteckenden indischen virusvariante in
weiten teilen des landes durften
touristenattraktionen museen kinos und
sportstätten öffnen pubs und restaurants
wie der gäste im innenbereich bedienen
freunde und familie dürfen sich nun ganz
offiziell wieder näher kommen auch
auslandsreisen sind möglich der nächste
öffnungs schritt ist für den 21 juni
geplant dann sollen alle beschränkungen
in großbritannien aufgehoben werden
in deutschland geht die zahl der
neuinfektionen weiter zurück das robert
koch institut weist aber erneut darauf
hin dass sich an dem langen wochenende
über fire und brückentag weniger
menschen testen ließen und somit die
gesundheitsämter weniger meldeten
innerhalb von 24 stunden registrierte
das lka 5412 neue fälle über 1500
weniger als vor einer woche
64 todesfälle kam hinzu die bundesweite
sieben tage ins events liegt die gestern
bei 83,1 wenn dann demnächst viele obst
gelockert werde kommt es umso mehr auf
den im fortschritt ansagen epidemiologen
letztlich hängt das natürlich vor allem
davon ab wie viel impfstoff da ist der
wird nicht dadurch mehr dass die
priorisierung aufgehoben wird
aber vielleicht kann so das tempo erhöht
werden weil die vergabe nicht mehr an
individuellen berechtigungen hängt die
umfänglich dokumentiert werden müssen
spätestens ab juni soll jedenfalls die
impf priorisierung bundesweit aufgehoben
werden dann dürfen alle ab 16 jahren
einige bundesländer handhaben das für
die arztpraxen jetzt schon so fällt die
priorisierung weg können die ärzte ohne
den bisherigen zusätzlichen
bürokratischen aufwand ihre spritzen
setzen auch die betriebsärzte dürfen
dann mit dran
womit sich die frage nach den
impfzentren stellen
kauft man die dann überhaupt nur dem
thema hat sich elisabeth schmidt befasst
sie sollten den impf turbo zum laufen
bringen
doch oft gibt es diese schlagzeilen
impfstoffmangel einige zentren müssen
tageweise schließen
teure leere hallen nach einer zdf
umfrage bei den zuständigen ministerien
der länder kostet der betrieb der
impfzentren in deutschland jeden monat
gut 220 millionen euro mindestens und
eine spritze im impfzentrum kostet laut
ärztevertretern bis zu 13 mal soviel wie
beim hausarzt in den praxen wird eine
impfung mit 20 euro abgerechnet in
impfzentren kostet diese bis zu 256 euro
unter gesundheitspolitikern mehren sich
stimmen die eine schließung der
impfzentren fordern im zentren sollten
ein auslaufmodell sein und nur noch für
zwei impfungen zur verfügung stehen also
für diejenigen patienten die die
erstimpfung schon bekommen haben und
ihren zweiten termin im zentrum haben
hauptposten der impfzentren das personal
unter anderem honorare für ärzte
hilfskräfte und verwaltungsangestellte
anders als bei den hausärzten die
patientendaten digital verarbeiten
müssen impfzentren impf berechtigungen
anamnese bogen oder ins bescheinigungen
sowohl digital als auch analog
archivieren
mit bis zu 50 aktenordner pro tag nur
hier in hannover
die kolleginnen kollegen vor ort haben
wir schon übersee container gemietet um
die sagten ordner dort verstauen zu
dürfen die haus herzlichen aber auch
betriebs herzliche strukturen müssen
jetzt stärker greifen
dort ist man ja von der bürokratie
gottseidank abgewichen
doch das schneider ratet hausarzt in
braunschweig spricht für die deutsche
gesellschaft für allgemeinmedizin und
sagt hausärzte hätten von beginn an mit
impfen können denn die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde habe früh erläutert
dass die meisten impfstoffe durchaus
einige tage im kühlschrank einer praxis
aufbewahrt werden könnten
doch statt die hausärzte zu fragen habe
der bund die impfzentren aufgebaut
manch einer hat sich gedacht da fällt
nicht so auf dass die kampagne nicht so
schnell in gang kommt weil wenn sie uns
50.000 hausärztinnen und hausärzte sind
impfstoff ausgeliefert hätten und wir
wären um 8 uhr 23 fertig gewesen und
dann
wer der impfstoff alle gewesen das hätte
jeder gemerkt wenn sie aber eine lange
schlange vor in einem der wenigen
zentren sehen denken sie auch das geht
ja gut voran
diesen vorwurf will die union so nicht
stehen lassen
zu beginn der impfkampagne habe nur
wenig impfstoff zur verfügung gestanden
dieser impfstoff der verfügbar war der
musste sinnvoll gerecht verwendet werden
dafür haben wir in großer einmütigkeit
eine priorisierung beschlossen die dann
dann auch sehr konsequent von den
impfzentren umgesetzt worden ist mit
aufhebung der impf priorisierung ist
dieses argument hinfällig
wann die impfzentren heruntergefahren
werden entscheiden die bundesländer die
meisten verträge mit den impfzentren
laufen mindestens bis ende september
so lange wird weiter teuer parallel
geimpft in zentren und hausarztpraxen
es gebe menschen und gruppen die durch
die korona krise entzweit oben sagte der
bundespräsident gestern zum abschluss
des kirchentags nach der pandemie
müssten brücken gebaut werden in der tat
gab und gibt es viele verwerfungen vor
allem wenn schicksale gegeneinander
aufgerechnet werden
auf der einen seite das leid durch das
virus mit krankheit und tod
auf der anderen seite das leiden das
durch die eindämmung maßnahmen entsteht
man kann sich im leid aber auch
verbünden das zeigt unser hamburger
kollege ralf zimmermann von sie gesagt
das ist eigentlich die bühne der
sopranistin christina stanik doch
derzeit sieht es so aus die sängerin an
der hamburgischen staatsoper ohne
publikum dafür mit einem patienten dem
54-jährigen ivan kirr der schwer an
krebs erkrankt war und dem sie mit ihren
atemtechniken sehr helfen konnte im
grunde geht es um das richtige atmen und
das wiedererlangen des ursprünglichen
lungenvolumen ich war natürlich auch
unsicher zu beginnen
ob die übung überhaupt etwas bringen
weil ich bin keine atemtherapeutin aber
das war für mich tatsächlich das größte
geschenk der ganzen sache dass er da
jetzt 20 prozent also von 40 auf 60
prozent lungenkapazität zurückgekommen
ist ivan kirr hat immer viel sport
gemacht in seinem leben aber cupid hat
ihn total aus der bahn geworfen
doch allein die bislang sechswöchige
begleitung mit atemübungen macht ihm mut
seine ursprüngliche körperliche fitness
bald wieder zu erlangen
es fühlt er sich an diesen eisenring
währung um die lunge ist jetzt dass
alles sich immer wieder zu drückt den
habe ich erstmal gestoppt und dann noch
durchbrochen und es ist einfach der
lebensqualität wieder spazieren zu gehen
und durchatmen zu können und diese drei
haben das ganze projekt initiiert ein
opern intendant und zwei
universitätsmedizin
dabei geht es um eine einfach klingende
medizinische not die das virus
verursacht die stärkung der muskulatur
das wieder aus denen des brustkorbs das
tiefe einatmen aber vor allen dingen die
kräftigung das ist das was die sängerin
mit den
patienten trainieren auch franziska
pusch hatte die krankheit schwer
getroffen
zwölf wochen lang war die 33-jährige
nicht nur außer gefecht sondern auch
kaum leistungsfähig nicht mal ihre
treppe kam die sehr sportliche ärzte
mehr richtig hoch das wie abgeschmiert
werden hat keine luft bekommen
es hat alles nur geschwätz also man
konnte gar nicht die atemmuskulatur die
dafür eigentlich zuständig ist jetzt
mitzuhelfen die konnte ich gar nicht
einsetzen methode immer nur durch die
nase einatmen jana kurucová ist auch
opernsängerin in hamburg die gebürtige
tschechin hat sich in der pandemie als
atem coach extrem nützlich gemacht eine
gute atmung durch die nase so ihr credo
ist nicht nur für kranke aber besonders
für die ein muss und ihre patientin
franziska pusch ist ihr bestes beispiel
ich habe selber nicht geglaubt dass es
so schnell geht dass man solche erfolge
so schnell quasi feiern kann
so hat die staatsoper in hamburg einigen
ihrer sängerinnen einen ganz neuen sinn
gegeben
in einer zeit in der das virus der kunst
und der kultur das leben mehr als schwer
macht
und jetzt nochmal bundes lag zunächst
mit dem blick auf die finanzwelt ja an
den börsen war zu diesem wochenauftakt
das auf und ab von digital währungen
insbesondere des it kein thema den
anlass gab erneut tesla chef elon musk
der nun seit monaten in sachen bitcoin
von sich reden macht frank bethmann was
steckt dahinter
da der gebürtige südafrikaner ist
mittlerweile für den bitkom tatsächlich
das was führende notenbanker für dollar
euro oder yen sind seit einigen monaten
bereits steuert er die wichtigste crypto
währung der welt nicht weil er ein
mandat hat sondern weil er es kann durch
tweets und eigene investments und so
bestimmt der bitcoin fan und tesla chef
zu wochenbeginn wieder die schlagzeilen
in grünheide bei berlin überprüfte er
den baufortschritt seiner neuen
autofabrik gleichzeitig wies er via
twitter zurück seine firma hätte
bitcoins verkauft zuvor hatte es wilde
kurssprünge bei der cyber währung
gegeben und immer hatte mast seine hände
mit im spiel im februar gab tester
bekannt 1,5 milliarden dollar ein
bitcoin investiert zu haben
außerdem begannen das unternehmen damit
bitcoins als zahlungsmittel zu
akzeptieren
vergangene woche dann der überraschenden
rückzieher davon der bitcoin habe eine
zu schlechte umweltbilanz verbrauche
viel zu viel strom produziert auch aus
kohle
wie viel strom genau ist erschreckend
weltweit verschlingt die krypto währung
inzwischen fast 100 39 terawattstunden
pro jahr das entspricht beinahe einem
viertel des gesamten jährlichen
deutschen strombedarfs private haushalte
und industrie zusammen genommen und von
alledem will ausgerechnet der visionäre
maske bis letzte woche nichts gewusst
haben
das kaufen ihm seine kritiker nicht ab
vielen dank für diese einblicke damit
künftig mehr menschen vom flugzeug auf
die bahn umsteigen soll der
grenzüberschreitende zugverkehr in
europa verbessert werden darauf
verständigten sich auch mit dem ziel des
klimaschutzes die eu-verkehrsminister
und vertreter der bahnindustrie beim
sogenannten schienen gipfel neuen 18
angebote sowie schnellere verbindungen
zwischen europas großstädten sollen das
bahnfahren attraktiver machen
das ziel sei ein europäischer
taktverkehr der bundesverkehrsminister
scheuer zwei personalien aus der
fußballwelt national torhüter marc andre
ter stegen fällt für die
europameisterschaft in diesem sommer aus
der 29 jahre alte schlussmann hat sich
mit seinem verein fc barcelona auf eine
notwendige knieoperation verständigt ter
stegen war für das turnier vom 11 juni
bis 11 juli von bundestrainer löw als
ersatzmann hinter stammtorwart manuel
neuer vorgesehen
fritz keller ist als dfb präsident
zurückgetreten wie bereits letzte woche
angekündigt der 64 jährige zog damit die
konsequenz aus seiner verbalen
entgleisung als er im april
vizepräsident rainer koch mit nazi
richter roland freisler verglichen hatte
in seiner rücktrittserklärung prangerte
keller interne machtkämpfe beim dfb an
es ist ein abgang mit scharfer kritik am
weltweit größten sportfachverband auf
der dfb internetseite ist fritz keller
stellungnahme zu lesen
seine amtszeit sei geprägt gewesen von
einem anhaltenden machtkampf der
zerstrittenen verbandsführung die
durchsetzung meines programms und meines
auftrags durch den dfb bundestag wurde
mir an vielen stellen immer wieder
schwer bis unmöglich gemacht
der dfb muss sich verändern er muss
seine glaubwürdigkeit das vertrauen in
seine integrität und leistungsstärke
zurück gewinnen
übergangsweise wird der kriselnde
verband nun von den beiden vize
präsidenten peter peters links und
rainer koch geführt der dreizehnte dfb
präsident fritz keller war nicht mal
zwei jahre im amt wer nachfolger oder
nachfolgerin wird ist noch völlig offen
das was von uns leichter dem wetter geht
es im montagskino weiter und nazan
dürfte mir meldet sich mit unserem
heute-journal update heute um kurz nach
halb eins und ein heute schneit es dann
morgen wieder darauf wieder sehen
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren sondern
ich höchst temperaturen von 35 grad gibt
es morgen hier an der algarve und auch
nördlich von moskau liegen die
höchsttemperaturen bei 30 grad in
mitteleuropa dagegen gibt es morgen nur
werte um die 15 grad das liegt an
schienen tief sie von großbritannien
kommen über ungern ziehen und
schlussendlich richtung skandinavien
weiter ziel eine wetterberuhigung ist er
erstmal nicht in sicht und so gibt es
auch heute nacht noch etliche schauer
bei temperaturen zwischen 10 grad am
oberrhein und 5 grad am alpenrand
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen bei
elf grad am alpenrand und 17 grad werden
hier in dresden aber auch in magdeburg
oder in berlin erreicht und auch morgens
wieder ein sehr wechselhafte tag
vielleicht sehen sie zwischen der
nordseeküste dem erzgebirge die sonne
auch mal länger aber spätestens am
nachmittag müssen sie sich dann auch
dort auch schauer und gewitter
einstellen bei westwind und mit diesem
sehr wechselhaften wetter geht es auch
in den nächsten tagen weiter am
mildesten wird es da noch am freitag mit
höchsttemperaturen von 13 bis 19 grad
und jetzt verlassen wir mitteleuropa und
fliegen ganz woanders hin nämlich in den
inn dick im in weg heißen die tropischen
wirbelstürme zyklone und der zyklon
tochter hat hier die westküste indiens
erreicht und ist da in den vergangenen
48 stunden weiter nach norden gezogen
er wird jetzt in diesen stunden an land
an landen dann hat er noch
windgeschwindigkeiten von über 150 km
pro stunde
guten abend